I have a I have a high blood pressure
and a diabetes and I I have the urgency
urination I don't know what will I be
okay
okay do you have a back problem not
really
before you stupid ma'am okay okay now
how much you weigh 150 headaches okay
all right so here's I want you to get
rid of all the bad stuff no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no gluten no
sugar cuz you're diabetic then at 156
and heavy take to the healthy brain your
heart packs per month the full dose
serving at breakfast in better time
because you have diabetes to support
healthy blood sugar and healthy
carbohydrate and sugar metabolism
silver-level once you get two bottles
amount of the sweeties you can take
three of those at breakfast and dinner
time to get one bottle of monk the glue
code gluco genex so you can take two of
those tablets at lunch time and then
again for the high blood pressure i want
you to get two bottles a month of the
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those points today it'll
support a healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries and support healthy
blood pressure and let's see here I
think it covers everything um yeah I
think that covers everything so no what
you do is to call me every two weeks and
I want to know when you call me I want
you to tell me your blood sugar levels
as English your levels when should tell
me about your blood pressure and so
forth and what I want you to do of
course is as your blood sugar drops and
it will you can reduce your medications
your doctors have taught you how to do
and I think that covers everything and
so I look forward to hearing from you
every two weeks if you have any
questions in between that feel free to
call but we look forward to having a
great testimony from you